welcome gulan students semester is
almost over with only two more episodes
left of gen V but worry not the show has
been renewed for a second season that
means there are only two more trailer
breakdowns left where we go over every
clip to see what could be in store now I
couldn't find this trailer online but I
was able to find it in the extra section
of genv on Amazon Prime in Canada I'm
hoping it's there in the US and
internationally too so you can give it a
look and come on back and before we
begin definitely be sure to like And
subscribe I do in-depth breakdowns of
each episode once they air the end of
episode 6 saw the gang banding together
to take on Dean chett so it's no
surprise we see that Marie here has
snuck into her office we can see the
same stained glass windows behind her I
wonder how they got in here was the door
open did they have to use one of their
powers or did they use Rufus they
already set up that he works in the
Dean's office we also see Jordan here
and she may have access to parts of the
school since she used to be Brink ta
Marie uncovers this blue file folder
from the top here it looks to contain
newspaper clippings and if we switch
over to this shot we can see the file
folder opened on shed's desk which
appears to contain photos considering we
have the dean saying this in the trailer
all of the sacrifices will finally pay
off I think we're getting a huge shete
reveal it sounds weird saying that so
what could be in this file folder
information on Marie or her sister
documents about the woods a connection
to Victoria Newman who we'll see later
on or perhaps something about the dean's
past if you haven't seen my episode 6
breakdown video I'll leave a link to it
below I have a whole section on how Dean
Shetty might have gone Rogue to avenge
her daughter's death you have a
daughter I did here we have Dr cardosa
and the dean back at the woods watching
one of the containment cells last
episode we saw the dean ask the doctor
if he could make the soup killing virus
contagious in the season trailer
trailers will see further experiments on
these poor prisoners with one looking
particularly ragged it's hinted that one
or more of these prisoners escapes which
would be bad news if one of them brings
the virus out into the world Marie has a
one-on-one with vice presidential
candidate Victoria Newman who you may
remember as the head popping soup from
The Boys season 2 and three it's
possible that Victoria wanted to meet
the top ranked students at gulan but my
guess is that Victoria is this
mysterious benefactor Dean Shetty told
Dr cardosa about in episode 5 I say this
because Marie and Victoria have a lot in
common both killed their parents both
can control blood in someway and both
attended the Red River Institute Marie
says to Victoria I can't just go back to
being a student when this whole school
is alive this would imply that a
Victoria knows about what's going on at
gulan and B that she wants Marie to
continue attending regardless does
Victoria want Marie to be a spy for her
or is there a world where the release of
this virus would actually be in Marie's
best interest one of the things I love
about this show is that they can take
these crazy scenarios and spin them in
such a way as to make them believable so
I'm excited to see how this plays out
whatever Victoria is offering she says
in the season trailer this is your shot
at real power Jordan and Marie hide
under the dean's desk they are hiding
from this guy unfortunately he's all
blurred is it some sort of janitor
cleaning up or is someone else snooping
around now this image sets up a lot
about what this episode is all about
Victoria Newman is on campus to do a
town hall with Cameron Coleman of VA
news Newman is considered anti- soup and
as director of the Federal Bureau of
superhuman Affairs Works to investigate
and prosecute soups the irony here is
that she is one herself although that's
still a secret to the public so it makes
sense that there would be protests here
the town hall looks to be a powder cake
with anti- and pro soup supporters mixed
together and getting riled up if you
look closely you'll see some familiar
faces in the crowd Rufus with the red
magga style hat here is Right alongside
Sam and Rufus definitely seems to be
riling up this crowd there's also this
guy in the white shirt who can blow ice
from his mouth creating an awesome slip
and slide my guess is that Emma's
brought Sam to lay low in the gulan
dorms in this shot it looks like Sam is
using a door to block the ice from
reaching this girl now Rufus and his
friends get Sam to join them in their
fun which involves drinking and sliding
but before you know it Sam is caught up
with Rufus and his friends going to this
protest this is why we see Emma
particularly concerned probably because
she has no idea where Sam is here we see
Andre running across campus as
protesters carry their signs we'll see
him running towards This Global Wellness
Services ambulance Global Wellness
Services is the vot funded hospital
system inside is his father polarity who
we can see here wearing the same shirt
when he's giving a speech we can see the
name Cameron Coleman in the background
so it's possible he's doing an interview
about everything that's going on at
gulin but what is happening to polarity
was he attacked or is this merely a
health issue like a heart attack we'll
see this shot of the ambulance swerving
away as Andre attempts to prevent the
ambulance from being crushed this makes
me think that they're not being attacked
rather whatever health issue polarity
has is making him convulse and unleash
his powers the swerves in Andre's face
here also seem to suggest something
happens to the driver making the
ambulance go Haywire now we do see Andre
here at what could be a hospital or as
these diagonal beams in the background
would suggest VA Tower with polarity
being a former member of the seven it's
possible he was taken there to get the
best care I will say the one piece of
evidence that they may be attacked comes
from these Sparks on the side of the
vehicle but let me know which Theory you
think will happen Kate here looking like
she's having another bad day she has her
cell phone in her hand maybe she got
some bad news or is dealing with her
mind Powers this shot of a concerned
Emma could have something to do with
finding out Sam's missing or maybe the
steel prison Windows have closed locking
her in compare this shot to when Andre
pulls them down in episode 5 and let me
know what you think we still haven't
seen this shot of students trying to
escape the dorms as these giant metal
doors close on them now listen again to
this line from Dean Shetty all of the
sacrifices will finally pay off we're in
Dean shed's home and the only other
people that we know so far who have
sacrificed for her are Dr cardosa and
Kate but I just have a feeling it's not
either of them with showrunner Eric kryy
stating that season 1 of genv ties into
season 4 of the boys I got to believe
the person Dean shett is talking to is
Victoria Newman that these two are
working together somehow it's no secret
that Victoria doesn't like homelander in
fact she willingly gave her daughter
compound v as a means to better protect
her against people that may seek her
harm it would be in Victoria's interest
for Shetty to develop a virus that takes
Powers away it would give her leverage
against homelander but does Victoria
know that Chetty has gone and made the
virus both lethal and contagious
remember that Chetty probably doesn't
know that Victoria is also a soup and
she may think this is what Victoria
really wants considering her anti-p
sentiment I am really excited to see how
this plays out the town hall looks to
completely break down we have ice breath
guy charging up an ice attack a scream
ability soup knocking someone over and
and one of rufus's friends who we saw in
the background of episode 2 using a
laser beam attack to rip off an American
flag not sure if he was aiming for
Victoria here but it seems whatever said
or happens at this town hall does not
sit well with the soups so that's it for
this trailer breakdown I want to hear
what you think will happen in the
comments below thanks for watching
please make sure to like And subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on Twitter and Instagram @ thinkstory YT
until next time remember holy
a lot is
happening